I see you returned
you may remember our last cruise through
Gore Lane where we highlighted some of
gaming's top gory deaths and today we're
back to bring you even more there are
tons of brutal and gut-wrenching moments
in games but the kicker here remains the
same everyone must die so sit back relax
and try to keep your lunch down here are
11 more gory game deaths test from the
last of us was as tough as nails and she
wouldn't hesitate to drop a few slugs in
you if she didn't like what she had to
say but of all the bodies she caught
before her noble sacrifice to save Joel
and Ellie she really knocked it out of
the park with this one I can see his
brains being trapped on an abandoned
ship with money-hungry killers is one
thing accidentally huffing
hallucinogenic gas while you're at it oh
that's where things really take a turn
for the worse you find all of your
characters in mana Madonna in some sort
of life-or-death situation many times
but if a rat bursts out of my stomach
screeching for air I would stab myself
[Music]
[Applause]
wolfenstein has a long history of blood
and gore and the torch has been passed
on to the terror twins right from the
start we witness a charming sisterly
love moment and also the complete
destruction of this Nazis head
[Music]
between soaps simultaneous cheering and
vomiting and Jess's realization of
brains in the mouth I'd say their first
kill was a success well done ladies you
can't think of gore without thinking of
creative even his finishers on the
smallest of minions deserve a spot here
but our next death goes to the bridge
keeper and 28 teens God of War the
mighty son of hell is said to be the
toughest role of all but this doesn't
stop him from catching the business from
Kratos and his blades of chaos like all
previous troll fights
Kratos tries to liquefy a Hilson skull
with his own totem but he manages to
resist however he can't resist his
inevitable death as Kratos rips a total
min half and plummets the blades of
chaos into his eyes for the final blow
all before you know ripping out his
heart
[Music]
Grand Theft Auto 5 served up plenty of
brutal moments but this is one in
particular that soars above the rest
Molly Schultz may have been Devin
Weston's right-hand woman but after the
hangar scene well she's only just a
right hand and a bunch of vets ah yes
here is a for the game that showed me I
could get beaten to death with my own
arm I even remember the first time I saw
someone in half after gunning them down
in Gears obviously but that's just one
of many executions in the series that is
full of that gory goodness however an
execution from Gears 5 is getting the
spotlight today no curb no problem our
gun will work just fine
by now dead space 2 really doesn't need
an introduction I'm still scarred from
that eye needle it's one of many
traumatizing deaths from that game and
yet they're not afraid to give it to you
straight from the start the opening
scene alone let me know Dead Space 2 was
not for the faint of heart
and that's why our boy Franco gets the
next spot
I'm not sure what's worse getting gutted
through the torso getting injected with
alien through the skull or having your
new alien Overlord be two sizes too big
and stretching you out to make space in
re sevens not a hero
our pal Chris Redfield is on the hunt
for Lucas Baker and more information
behind the Baker incident all together
now whenever it comes to the Baker's I
know some messed up [ __ ] is about to
happen everything's all right now
oh how that could not be further from
the truth although I appreciate Chris
Redfield's optimism here even the
soldier he's trying to save knows what's
up as toxic gas burst into the room we
then watch helplessly as this poor guy's
neck gets shredded to pieces and his
head falls to the floor they even made
sure he got his helmet crack so you can
look into his lifeless dead eye as you
snatch his filter to survive that's low
we had to do it kratos is so nice he's
featured twice this iconic boss fight in
God of War 3 is the perfect show of
dominance as Kratos uses his pure
strength and rage to grip and rip Helios
his head completely off his body the
stretching and tearing of the skin mixed
with Helios his final shriek followed by
the fountain of spewing blood really
burns this one into my brain
[Applause]
good all doom the evolution of doom
through the years has given us even more
gore with every iteration if you haven't
seen doom eternals glory kills ya then
you're in for a treat but today's spot
is going to be unique glory kill against
the spider mastermind in 2016 doom
shoving my BFG down the spider demon's
throat and blowing its brains to pieces
is not only visually satisfying but each
and every sound effect is all the gory a
smart I'll ever need although I do wish
there was more time to enjoy it before
getting whisked away let's be real here
I just put every fatal blow brutality
and fatality from MK 11 alone on this
list and it would be perfectly fine
notorious for blood and gore MORTAL
KOMBAT absolutely tops the charts and
knowing it down to one is nearly
impossible
nearly Erin blacks deathtrap fatality
leaves nothing to the imagination
ripping a hole in some it's pourcel with
a bear trap to make way for our rifle
into the bloody gaping canal just to put
the barrel up the throat is one hell of
a way to pop someone's melon but I got
to give credit to both the eyeballs
getting ejected from the skull - there
you have it folks did you make it this
far 11 more gory Dean deaths are in but
has your sanity checked out have you
seen enough are you looking for more let
us know in the comments what your
favorite gory deaths are in be sure to
check out part 1 if you haven't already
thanks for watching
you